By working with Lady Gaga, obviously, you know...
...her fans open up and a lot of them like my music and go to my shows.
And that's a great thing for me...
...because I don't always want to stick with the small amount of fans that like, go and try dance music.
I wanted the metalheads to love my songs and be able to go to my shows...
...and I want older people that probably have never heard electronic music before...
...to at least be able to find something interesting...
...because my music is, you can play it on the piano, that's what I sometimes do.
So I do acoustic versions to show that there's a whole another layer...
...that you don't probably hear because the kick drum is loud.